pourquoi est-il difficile
d'être une femme trans à porto rico
une pléthore de raisons
pour lesquelles vous savez que vous avez des gens qui sont tellement
préoccupés par ce qu'il y a entre vos
jambes
[Musique]
ils sont tellement préoccupés par le fait que vous ayez l'air
différent qu'ils ne peuvent même pas écouter  ton
objectif
ils ne peuvent même pas écouter ton rythme cardiaque
ils oublient que tu es un être humain
tu es déshumanisé
je fais de mon mieux pour au moins
survivre
et aider les autres à dire cette vérité
tout en profitant de leur vie tout en
sachant qu'ils '  re si belle
maison de grâce
[Musique]
donc les maisons sont ces structures euh
qui se forment parce que souvent
les personnes trans et les personnes queer n'ont pas de
famille où aller parce
qu'elles sont abandonnées par leurs familles biologiques la
plupart des filles sont  au début de la vingtaine,
à bien des égards, ces jeunes comme les jeunes
qui n'ont pas été affirmés dans leur
transité
recherchent des figures maternelles ou parentales
pour les
affirmer  s
oui tu es féminine et oui tu es
belle
[Musique
] beaucoup de gens ont seulement besoin d'entendre que
quelqu'un croit en eux
[Musique]
alors j'ai commencé à inviter des gens à la maison
vraiment par intuition
je cherchais des gens talentueux
qui étaient créatifs  et
qui avait ce que j'appelle un cœur d'or
[Musique]
depuis que je suis enfant, je me suis toujours noyé comme
des figures féminines
et comme mon père,
il avait un souci avec ça
quand j'étais enfant, il voulait que je
dessine plus  des personnages masculins qui sont tellement
ridicules, c'est comme pourquoi
mais vous savez que les gens sont tellement obsédés par le fait que
leurs enfants soient cisgenres
j'ai grandi avec trois sœurs plus âgées que
moi
euh et j'attendais toujours
qu'elles soient à l'école ou qu'elles soient une église à
aimer
essayez-leur leurs vêtements sur quelque chose que j'ai
fait depuis
presque six ans je crois que j'ai tenté de me
suicider à huit ans et
la raison pour laquelle j'ai tenté de me suicider était à
cause de l'
intimidation constante à l'école et pas seulement à l'
école mais
aussi la façon dont  ma famille a développé ma
spiritualité, c'était comme
aller vraiment trois fois par semaine à l'
église
pour écouter que j'allais en enfer mais
j'ai beaucoup guéri
j'ai encore beaucoup à guérir ma bio maman
ne sait pas que je suis une fille mais mon  l'autre
maman le fait donc
il y a euh je suis à moitié là tu sais que
maria m'a donné ça même si
je me sens comme un univers de miss avec ça
il y a potter rig ho et ça me va
je pensais que j'étais un fluage que je que
personne n'était comme moi tu sais  euh
peut-être juste peut-être que si j'avais
vu la maison de la grâce
à ce moment-là, j'aurais
pris une autre décision
[Musique]
donc depuis que j'ai 17 ans,
je suis un
peu seul euh
ma famille ne me soutient pas beaucoup les
adolescents devraient profiter de leur adolescence
et c'est une période très formatrice
donc c'était difficile mais je pense que j'ai
pris mes responsabilités et mes responsabilités
depuis que je suis une petite fille et
j'ai juste commencé à
demander si je suis une fille ou un garçon
est-elle une fille et une  des filles
dit qu'elle est une fille
oui fille je suis  une fille
mais ouais tu sais je pense que je le fais
fonctionner parce qu'il n'y a pas d'
autre option euh
je n'ai pas été seul mais comme je pense
que
j'ai fait de la place dans ma vie pour une vraie
famille
pour les gens qui m'aimaient vraiment m'ont embrassé
et honoré  de qui je
[Musique]
c'est comme une galerie euh que
j'aime
j'aime les graffitis et je pense que c'est
vraiment mignon
comme regarde les petits coeurs baise l'homme
oui
[Musique]
nous tous je pense quand nous nous sommes rencontrés étaient en quelque sorte
assez dans les processus de  découverte et
apprentissage de nous-mêmes nous
nous écoutons du mieux que nous
pouvons
de la manière dont nous
[Applaudissements]
et pouvons explorer la féminité et
nous savions que c'était sûr nous savions que
c'était bon
euh nous savions que nous n'allions pas  être
jugés
et que nous allions être célébrés
dans ces processus où que
nous soyons,
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont une
sorte d'âme sœur, donc j'ai juste l'impression
d'être autour d'eux
j'ai réussi à avoir 22 ans à ma manière spéciale
je  Je me suis amusé, je suis une fille amusante
ne pas essayer d'être
blonde c'était une sorte de modèle et c'était
quelque chose que vous savez très
unique mais je ne savais pas que c'était
que j'étais
trans
j'ai l'impression d'être comme un arc-en-ciel
je suis  comme tu sais une vie arc-en-ciel
pleine de couleurs je peux me sentir très
différente chaque jour et je et tu sais
ce que c'est que c'est fou
que je me sente toujours comme ça
quand j'ai commencé tu connais ma transition
physiquement
quand j'ai rencontré la maison et je  j'ai commencé à
recevoir ma thérapie hormonale
mais les choses qui étaient nouvelles c'était que
tu sais que je peux tu sais
que mon corps a l'air plus doux
mon corps et mon esprit est connecté maintenant
tu fais un pas de travers
ce n'est pas l'endroit
non pour nous ouais et  Pas comme les
filles comme
nous  puerto rico est 7,25
parce que je dois payer le loyer et la nourriture et
parce que je dois vivre, je dois passer
par e  comme tous les jours
et c'est vraiment très épuisant
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est un taser que House of
Grace m'a eu
euh bien sûr ce n'est
pas rien contre une arme à feu ou un
groupe de personnes mais quelque chose l'
avez-vous déjà utilisé je ne l'ai jamais utilisé
auparavant
et  Honnêtement, j'espère que je n'aurai pas à l'utiliser
parce que j'aime
euh je suis si doux tu sais quand il
s'agit d'aimer la violence et j'aime
ça euh ce n'est pas mon truc alors j'espère que je
n'aurai jamais à l'
utiliser mais si je  jamais besoin d'utiliser que je l'ai
bien primordialement nous sommes comme un groupe de
personnes qui se suivent
vous savez qu'il y a à la fois un besoin émotionnel et
matériel
que beaucoup de ces enfants
ont savoir si c'était avoir des gens qui
restent dans mon appartement
leur acheter de la nourriture leur
donner des vêtements du maquillage de l'
argent s'ils en avaient besoin ma maison je
voulais vraiment être un espace
où les noirs et les trans
peuvent se sentir comme s'ils se reposaient
comme s'ils étaient loin de la
violence qu'ils subissent au jour le jour
Je suis tellement reconnaissant pour des espaces comme celui-ci  et
aussi maison de grâce
et cela me donne de l'espoir pour l'avenir
parce que je sais qu'à puerto rico il
y a
tu sais des espaces créés par nous
car tu nous connais
pour choisir l'espoir de choisir l'amour pour choisir l'
art pour choisir d'aller de l'avant
euh  c'est déjà
un travail énorme
je ne prétends pas que mon corps est le
plus
transparent mais il est suffisamment transgressif
pour attirer l'attention des gens et
me faire me sentir bien
regardé je peux me sentir comme un
étranger
si je suis entouré de gens qui scrutent mon
corps
ce que j'aime
c'est un amour compliqué j'aime être
euh privé tu sais par merveille tu sais
combien de ce
euh désir d'intimité a à voir avec le fait d'
avoir été blessé
par d'autres c'est un peu vraiment comme un
tu sais que je protège mon oh
le travail de la fille
[Musique]
pourquoi être féminin signifiait dans les années 80
est différent de ce qu'être féminin
signifiait dans les années 2000
et c'est définitivement différent de ce que
cela signifie en 2020
voir mes hormones
tous les jours um
confrontations ou hormones vous deux oui
veille  Tous les jours,
j'ai sorti mes poils du visage pour
le
clip de Casablanca parce que je dis dans la chanson
comme ça que je suis une
fille poilue, je suis ravie d'en avoir fini avec
ça pour que je puisse
revenir à ne plus avoir de soin du visage  cheveux
tout pour l'esthétique
tu peux avoir des poils sur le visage
une moustache une barbe et être toujours très
féminine
tu peux être une femme poilue reine je suis
actuellement une femme poilue reine
et beaucoup de gens pensent que
le
but ultime des personnes trans est de passer pour passer
inaperçu dans la société
que si vous êtes des femmes trans, vous pouvez marcher
n'importe où et personne ne doutera de
votre féminité parce que vous passez pour dire
non à cela
pour dire non, je peux choisir mon propre chemin
et je peux me présenter de la manière qui se
sent  confortable
et possible pour moi en ce moment
je pense que c'est absolument transgressif
parce
que nous ne faisons pas ça pour être
digeste j'aime la fille toutes sortes de filles pas
seulement des filles avec des
vagins aussi des filles de pénis
c'est un monde formidable où il y a des femmes
de toutes  temps
[Musique]
pas de tapis  ter à quel point je prouve ma valeur
d'une manière ou d'une autre je vais toujours être
sans valeur ce n'est pas mon problème
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'il est encore plus important
de créer un
travail qui inspirera les jeunes trans
à se sentir comme s'ils avaient une place
dans le monde quelque chose à faire admirer aux gens
[Musique]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
étranger
[Musique]
donc c'est ma première fois
vous